DEVON NEARY: My
name is Devon Neary,
I'm the Community Outreach
Manager here at the CMA.
As you all know our
members across the country
face constant opposition
from environmental groups.
I'm here today to
propose some solutions
for working with these groups
[AUDIO OUT] against them.
Our most recent conflict
involved an environmental group
trying to block the expansion
of our southwest computer chip
factory on the grounds
that pollution is causing
a spike in local cancer rates.
So what should our goal be
in designing a working plan
with this environmental group?
I propose a strategy that is
different from how the CMA
usually conducts business.
I propose we sit down in
remediated negotiations
with the environmental
groups and explain
our side of the
issue, allow them
to explain their
side of the issue,
and find a consensus
for moving forward
that enables both
sides to achieve
their long-term aims given
the constraints of reality.
We want to open up a space
to collaborate and brainstorm
nonbinding options
as a means of moving
towards a binding agreement.
Why should this be our goal?
Environmental groups
pressure us and attempt
to block us at our sites
throughout the country.
These disputes have not improved
over the last few decades,
and it's time for a new approach
to make sure our projects
progress according to time
and financial constraints.
My research on this
issue supports the idea
that a consensus-building
approach can improve
outcomes for all parties.
Just for a little
bit of context,
in reality, our partners in
the environmental organization
do not have a lot of
legal ground to stand on.
Proving the cause of a specific
cancer in a specific individual
and tying it to a specific
chemical that came out
of our chip plant
on a specific day
is very challenging and
costly in a courtroom.
We can gently remind
environmentalists
that court is expensive,
adversarial, and often drawn
out.
Ultimately, our funding
and legal capabilities
will defeat theirs.
In addition, in times
of economic duress
and uncertainty,
local authorities
are going to make way
for our great industry
to create jobs and capital.
So in some sense,
there's no need for us
to engage with the
environmentalists.
Without the negotiation,
we'll probably
still get our expansion.
However, what I
want to point out
is that we can do better than
that through the negotiation.
We can prove our relationships
with environmentalists,
and we can make it easier and
less costly to do business
in the future.
I know many of you probably have
some hesitations about this.
Perhaps you feel a
fear of the unknown,
a fear that the
process will fail
or a fear that the negotiation
will be slow and costly.
But remember we're investing
for long-term gains
in our relationships with
surrounding communities.
I understand this is atypical
for our powerful industry
and there will be challenges.
As the views of the CMA and
the views of the environmental
groups differ radically.
The environmentalists may not be
ready or willing to negotiate.
They may be intent
on filing a lawsuit,
or they could draw
out the negotiations
in a disruptive manner.
Their ultimate
goal would probably
be to eliminate our plant, but
this is not a realistic demand.
Our plant is already
there and operating well,
so eliminating the
potential carcinogens
is not a feasible
option for them.
So what is the next best
option for the community?
Our strategy is
to think in terms
of what we can offer them to
appease some of their concerns
without giving up
anything precious to us.
Do they need health
clinics in their community?
Do they want a community
buyout so they can relocate?
Would they like a new
nature preserve or funding
for education?
For our part our members
have to decide away
from the table, how much
we are willing to give
to smooth out these
relationships and leverage
these concessions
in negotiations.
We need to find out what
people on both sides
are really willing to live with.
We can begin by addressing
their environmental concerns,
talking about issues
of leaks, accidents,
the increased rates of cancer
that they're observing.
How can we prove
to them that we are
in compliance with regulations
and protecting the abutting
communities?
We can also leverage what we
do well for the community.
We create jobs, we spur
economic development,
we make philanthropic
donations, provide job training.
My job is to get people excited
about chemical manufacturing
and all the wonderful
things we do for the country
and for the world.
The chips manufacturing
plant in question,
while maybe causing
some pollution,
is manufacturing
computer chips used
in a wide range of
industries including
defense, medical research,
education, and so on.
We believe that if residents
realize the contribution we
have in their community
and for the country,
they'll be more amenable
to negotiating with us.
So you want to focus
on two principles.
You want to focus on maintaining
relationships throughout.
And We want to focus
on mutual gains.
So we'll follow a process
based on a research
consensus-building approach.
When we are ready to negotiate
and the environmentalist
express that they
are ready, first we
will convene and assign roles.
For example, we need
to identify a mediator.
The mediator will schedule
and facilitate the meetings,
consult privately with groups
and push us to build consensus.
We also want to focus on
group problem solving.
How can we create
value as a group?
By brainstorming
different options together
based on our interests
and being creative,
we can present
alternative designs.
We can expand the means of
dealing with externalities
and try to create different
packages of benefits
we can offer the community.
Once we have created value,
we can talk about ways
to distribute value to
implement these goals
and to hold parties accountable
for their commitments.
So just to review the
benefits of engaging
in a successful negotiation
for our company.
It's an opportunity to educate
the community about our work
and our constraints to gain
some flexibility in when
and how requirements are
met and to smooth out
these longstanding
and disruptive
and conflicts with
environmentalists.
With the
environmentalists, they can
achieve better environmental
gains, reap added value,
and enforce stronger business
practices in their community
all at a lower cost.
Thank you.